hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
take the risk out of rotations
understanding and implementing biosafety
solutions in centrifugation
i am jennifer woods of labrutz and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by beckmann culture life sciences
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation i'd
like to now welcome our speaker
dr derek c lentz senior manager
biopharma
beckman culture life sciences dr lentz
you may now begin your presentation
hello and thanks for joining this talk
today
before we get into the topic i would
like to first thank
the team at lab roots for organizing
this
i'd like to thank you the audience for
your participation
and i'd like to thank my colleagues at
beckman culture life sciences
particularly renee curry
so my name is derek lenz i'm the senior
manager for biopharma at beckmann
culture life sciences
and today we're going to talk about i
think a very important topic that maybe
should be discussed a little more
frequently and that's to the
strategies that take the risk out of
rotations right really understanding
and implementing biosafety solutions as
they pertain
to centrifugation before we get
into the talk too much further
i do have to put up the obligatory
intellectual property slide this
document is confidential and proprietary
for beckman coulter
any disclosure or use without written
consent is prohibited so
let's dive in i have a few poll
questions that i'm going to present now
that i would like
to explore a little bit more after the
presentation with you during the panel
discussion
so here's the first question really
trying to get at your familiarity with
the
individuals within your organization
that comprise your bio safety committee
so there are some options there yes i
know them all
i can't name a single person or i'm not
sure so that's the first question
how familiar are you with the
individuals
in the biosafety committee of your
organization
here's the second poll question how
often does your organization
perform these bio safety audits of
laboratory facilities
and there are some options there for you
to select
and again we'll have these up at the
panel discussion
something we we can talk about together
so for the next poll question the third
one
uh true or false i'm familiar with 42
cfr 73 and related federal guidelines
for
lab biosafety true or false
and then the last poll question also a
true and false question
i would like to feel a little safer
about biosafety please have my local
beckman representative reach out to me
true or false
okay let's dive into the talk
starting with an introduction i i think
it's important to note that since the
inception of modern biology
really biosafety has involved evolved
into a critical consideration for good
laboratory practices
i think gone are the days of course the
jokes of mouth pipe heading
and doing things that really put us and
others in harm's way
and with the recent and rapid expansion
that we see in biopharma and the use of
biologics and research and disease i
think biosafety becomes
an even more critical topic in the
context of good laboratory practices
i think the challenge here though is is
many of us think that
biosafety is a one-size-fits-all
perspective
which is not the case there are
oversight committees and organizations
yes that do define and manage these
these guidance frameworks however there
is a
portion of this equation that is the
responsibility of the individual labs
they need to be able to assess implement
monitor
and maintain standards in a way that's
unique to their environment so we're
going to explore that a little bit more
here's our key objectives for today
the the four major buckets we're going
to talk about considerations associated
with biosafety
we'll speak a little bit about good
laboratory practices specifically for
centrifugation that's really the
the product we're talking about today
there are obviously other considerations
for other platforms that we can consider
but today's centrifugation
and then we're going to talk about some
workflows related to
separation and centrifugation and look
at how we can mitigate risk
contain and control monitor and report
what we're seeing and then we'll
summarize and conclude
okay so let's start off with the
considerations associated with biosafety
if you if you really look at biosafety
the key here is to maintain
biological integrity but that
also means the integrity of you the
individuals in the lab and the greater
ecology
so human health and ecology are part of
this equation when we discuss
biosafety and i think it's important
obviously to establish
that we all know it's to protect from
harmful incidences
yes and failure here really
increases our risk of exposure so we're
not going to say necessarily that by not
doing
a b or c that something is going to
happen
we instead want to take a perspective of
where am i
increasing my risk of exposure and how
can i control that
so that we don't have any failures
so when you look at
the literature the data in the
marketplace the analysis of studies
the two largest sources of unnecessary
exposure
or increase of risk are these two topics
here
poor techniques and tools and human
error
so these two areas alone comprise the
major source of where unnecessary
exposure can occur
and the key parameters that we want to
consider within
biosafety are cited here we really want
to have a plan for risk mitigation
we want to understand the controls we
have in place
to contain or to prevent things from
getting
um more problematic and then what are
the mechanisms that we use to monitor
and report so that we can make changes
when necessary
or we can demonstrate compliance with
these safeties
so overall i think this is the key areas
that we want to consider
when we discuss biosafety
now the challenge here i think with this
is
it's not an all-encompassing under one
roof situation here
we have multiple organizations and
groups all working together towards the
same goal
so first and foremost you have a
regulatory agency
providing those guidelines and that can
differ by geography and by industry
but certainly there's an agency giving
comment
and from there those comments and
regulatory suggestions
should be internalized by an
organization's enforcement committee
it really should be a group of
individuals that understand the
guidelines and what these regulatory
agencies
want to accomplish and then to take them
and put them
into their specific environment to
maximize
compliance with guidelines and to reduce
risk
of exposure and that
is where we the laboratory personnel
come in
those of us working with potential
biohazards
have a role in biosafety we need to be
able to
understand who our enforcement members
are
in the committee we need to understand
what rules and considerations they would
like us to follow
and then we have to be involved actively
with the process to help them
and really when it comes down to uh
working with the lab
our goal is ongoing risk assessment and
regular review
now if we look at the regulatory agency
piece at the top a little bit
we have something with the cartagena
protocol on biosafety so this is an
international standard for agricultural
definitions
but there's a push to expand the
dominion into biopharma
so this is a very all-encompassing
comprehensive
protocol attempting to completely define
the full scope of biosafety
considerations
in the context of the united states it's
a little bit different
we have the center for disease control
that defines and gives comment on
different bio safety
levels and what the associated
containment precautions are for those
levels
there's a big focus on infectious
materials
which is just one part of biosafety
considerations
and there's escalating or rising levels
one through four
so a little bit different in the united
states we don't have an
all-encompassing single protocol like
the cartagena protocol
internationally but we do have an
organization like the cdc
lending their expertise on infectious
materials
from there we have the fda involved as
well so the u.s
food and drug administration is actually
responsible in tasks with
creating the standards for biologics
from cell lines so for example
viral safety evaluation so we can see
here in this example the way the
structure is set up
there may be a little overlap a little
confusion a little gray area
as to where one organization in the u.s
may have a role
and where that may overlap with another
organization
and so i think we see right away just
from the approach of how we want to
accomplish biosafety
that there may be some room for
confusion and so it's important that we
understand these details
and mitigate that confusion so again in
the u.s
there's no unifying regulatory authority
but the comment is very complete and
concise
we contrast that with the rest of the
world the international compute
community
they have a single organization that we
can point to
that is responsible for biosafety yet
the regulatory comment is still
incomplete
so now let's consider these associated
bio
safety levels from the cdc to begin with
we're going to dive in
to really u.s requirements for the
remainder of this talk
so classification of biohazards right
specifically refers
to how we handle organs tissues
biologics
that could potentially transfer disease
to us we have environmental
controls in place to promote safety
right the health care workers the
researchers and so forth
and then the objective really is
according to the cdc
monitoring for occupationally acquired
diseases right
and that can be challenging
when we look at these different risk
groups the cdc considers
other listed here with risk group one
being very low or no risk
to the individual or to the community so
this is how the cdc wants to weigh these
risks
what's the risk the individual what's
the associated risk to the individual
within that community
and so it escalates to moderate risk to
the individual maybe low risk to the
community
could be a pathogen that causes disease
but is unlikely to be a full biohazard
and then it escalates all the way up to
the fourth group which is a high risk
to the individual as well as the
community
and really the definition there can
cause disease and is readily
transmissible
so from the perspective of the cdc this
is how they classify biohazard
based on these four risk groups so now
if we look at some of the comments that
they make here
the classification of biohazard
materials is subjective
and risk assessment is determined by
individuals
most familiar with specific
characteristics this is an interesting
comment and i think it's the right one
from the cdc
what they are essentially extending is
you the individual
know your research dynamics and details
better than us on the outside you have
an active
role in helping the community through
the cdc
to really understand and determine risk
assessment so we play a role as
experts and without our role this
process
is not complete so says the cdc
now let's look at some bio safety levels
these bsls where i think we're all
fairly familiar with this concept i just
want to make sure we're all kind of on
the same page with the details
so these are bio containment precautions
to isolate potentially dangerous
agents there are equivalent criteria as
you see here in the eu and in
canada and so
let's go through these real quick we
have bsl1 and here are some of the
details right
locked doors to limit access personal
protective equipment
only for instances when potential
exposure to biohazards occur
essentially i would say your standard
lab if you will
and then again escalating up
to bsl2 for escalating
potential conditions we may include a
biological safety
cabinet access may be limited to the
facilities or to the room when specific
work is being conducted
if it's a bsl level three it's all the
other aspects plus we consider
serious or lethal disease via inhalation
so it's all the conditions of bsl level
two
plus those that are cited here so as you
can see
these requirements escalate quite
steeply as we go up the process
all the way to bsl4 there is nothing
higher of course
it's designed for highly infectious
aerosolized
agents with no known vaccines or
treatments so
the the most dangerous of the dangers
and here you're talking about ppe with
positively pressurized configurations
[Music]
we may have an emphasis on more
automation in our workflows
as a means of mitigating risk and
exposure
and there are full decontamination
showers in and out of the facilities
so you can see that these these
parameters these conditions escalate
quite quickly
as a function of risk mitigation for
these potential biohazards
now diving into the world health
organization a little bit and how they
look at biosafety
in addition to these recommendations for
handling biohazardous materials
i think the who does a really nice job
for guidelines on state
safe handling of methods and materials
and staff training
maybe something that the cdc wasn't
tasked with or the fda
that i think the world health
organization is correct
on commenting on and here are some of
the additional
recommendations on handling right as i
mentioned to you early
using the tools appropriate tools and
using them appropriately
you can see here pipetting culturing
smearing and centrifugation
on list number two for the world health
organization
so i think it's important to point out
that the bio safety considerations if
we're doing it right may even extend
out of what the cdc and fda recommend
and we may be wise to consider some of
the suggestions and recommendations made
by who
now some further considerations from the
u.s code of federal regulation cfr for
short
and something we mentioned in the poll
questions is 42 cfr
73 um the first chapter through chapter
21.
this is comprised of comment regarding
occupational health and safety
the transportation of biohazards maybe
from one lab to another or
even one facility to another and then
the use of bio containment
and we're going to explore this theme
quite a bit more later on in the talk
considering your primary secondary
sources of containment and even further
down
in consideration now some of the factors
involved
with cfr and assessing an organism's
classification
are cited here the laws relating again
to biosafety
are not always easily accessible or
readily
clear i think as a consequence of trying
to make a comprehensive
solution we maybe have injected a little
bit of confusion and gray area into this
so there are readily available
regulations out there but for potential
trainees to reference
outside of publications recommended by
cfr
is somewhat lacking so what they
ultimately say is
training responsibilities for the lab
employers
and is not consistent across various
laboratory types
and this can really increase your risk
of accidents in the release of
biohazards
so here you have sort of a fundamental
shift away
from maybe what the world health
organization is recommending
in this case cfr is putting it on
us the individuals the employers of lab
personnel
to manage these classifications so an
area where
some potential risk is taken on by the
work that we do
so that's a little bit of the background
there i'd like to shift gears now
and take what we just discussed earlier
in the talk
and look at it in the context of good
laboratory practice
in in centrifugation and i think in my
mind the best way we can accomplish this
is risk minimization is probably the
most
logical course for mitigating the risk
itself right
if we can decrease the incidences of
this occurring
then hopefully we never have to worry
about mitigating a risk
so let's dive into this when it comes to
centrifugation and good laboratory
practices
the international electro technical
commission the iec is
is really the historical foundation um
for this topic and an organization a
commission that beckman culture life
sciences
has been involved with for a very long
time right for almost half a century
it's comprised of global stakeholders
it's tasked with standardizing testing
guidelines for lab instrumentation and i
show you a publication here below on the
slide
and really what they're trying to do is
comment and define
centrifuge lab safety so the standard i
recommend
most of us to look at is cited here it's
iec
61010-2-020
this is the international standard for
centrifuge lab safety
and i highly encourage those that are
involved in centrifuge workflows that
have not had a chance to review it
that this would be a good starting point
to really start assessing
and being an active participant
in ensuring that risk is minimized so
that exposure is mitigated
now let's dive into some of the key
elements of
of this comment from iec
when it's when it comes down to
centrifugation it's really about
particle containment
to assure that during a rotor accident
particles will not exit that that is the
key there
if there is an accident have i assured
that the particles are going to be
contained within the rotor
not the instrument itself not the
centrifuge but the rotor inside
and the assurance is is via an
intentional accident
with a rotor to determine the maximum
explosive energy
we call this the maximal credible
accident as you see here
mca now
the mca is actually the responsibility
of we
the manufacturers of the centrifuges so
beckman culture life sciences
determines the test conditions just like
the other manufacturers do as well
and we cite some of the important
parameters here the highest energy rotor
spun
at maximum speed or higher for example
we must provide this evidence to iec
to demonstrate that we are adhering with
this code
we need acceptance by iec leads to
certify by ul csa and ce
and most importantly here in the safety
standard
centrifuge testing involves creating an
extremely
large amount of energy so with these
accidents the rotors are over
sped and then we test whether they can
contain
particles over five millimeters in size
from falling
over one meter from the unit so this is
really where the details hit
five millimeter particles falling over
one meter
from the unit now
in the case of beckham culture life
sciences we perform our mcas
and what we affectionately reser refer
to as our block house in indianapolis
and in fact we've helped other
manufacturers because of the quality of
our block house and the expertise we've
demonstrated in over a half a century of
involvement with iec
we have very good understanding of the
criteria
and and the necessary requirements to
really
monitor and manage this maximum credit
credible accident
so the black house in indianapolis is
where we perform
our mca work on our centrifuges
so let's shift gears a little bit and
let's start talking about what the
largest sources of unnecessary exposure
are
in the context of centrifugation
as we mentioned earlier in the summary
part of the talk
core technique and tools and human error
are your two greatest sources whether
you are in the us
or anywhere else in the globe these are
what the data conclude
poor technique tools human error and
when combined
we see this very horrible picture down
on the right
of a centrifuge that was not maintained
properly
did not perform good laboratory
practices in an extreme case we had an
accident
now here we're showing that
it's not always obvious the problems
so in this particular case the rotor
being used
had a really small compromise in the
material as shown here from the red
arrow and the red
circle this little pit within this
container
and again the key here five millimeter
particles
one meter or further from the instrument
it's the rotor itself
that is meant to contain this not the
centrifuge
now diving down a little
deeper into the centrifuge system
are the tubes and bottles right these
crack in deform over time
i think many of us are extremely busy in
the lab we have
more work than we can handle and perhaps
maybe sometimes
we take unnecessary risks and we use
bottles and tubes that maybe have been
worn down over time so it's a good idea
to note the number of runs and have a
replacement plan
for these tubes and bottles right to get
ahead again
minimizing the risk if you're using
sealed or capped
tubes or bottles of course you want to
check for leaks
and i think something overlooked quite
frequently are the missing or damaged
o-rings
these form important seals that help
support
containing and minimizing risk
now for the user itself
typically the accidents occur from lack
of awareness or lack of experience right
lack of training i think many of us
such as myself right bright-eyed bushy
tail in grad school
and the professor starts designing your
experiments with you and
you're meant to go run off and start
executing these experiments
if you're not comfortable with all the
aspects
involved in centrifugation you may
quickly run into some trouble so lack of
awareness and experience
is certainly a big
portion of potential unnecessary
exposure
here's an example of these tubes as you
can see in the lower right
we're using these red scorings to denote
the physics and pressure that occur
as these tubes and bottles are spun so
in this case
on the lower left side here where the
force is greatest
you can start seeing where this
potentially could be the area where the
materials start to
form deformities or cracks over time so
again
important to note a replacement plan um
i list here i think some of the most
common user created accidents involved
i think in being honest to the group
i've probably been to blame for these
once or twice and maybe i just got lucky
right
not balancing the rotor as best i could
um
i'm too big of a hurry so i don't check
that the the buckets and hinges are
lubricated and not taking unnecessary
stress
um i think we've all been in a lab where
the person before us
failed to clean the dirty rotor okay so
not only is that maybe
inconsiderate but that individual is
certainly
increasing sources of unnecessary
exposure
so these things listed here really
important they might seem
minor in the scope of all the big
research and work we're doing every day
but these things add up to a potential
accident and accidents always happen at
the worst time right
so this is something i really want to
emphasize here
this may be a common
wisdom that is not wisdom at all but
maybe
a big potential error mismatching
manufacturers rotors tubes and
centrifuges
uh it happens we do it a lot it's a very
bad idea
when you look back at the maximum
credible accident and some of the
regulatory criteria
involved in defining bio safety and risk
minimization it is critical
to use the same manufacturers rotors
tubes and centrifuges
you're exposing yourself to unnecessary
risk
by mismatching these these instruments
are not designed
or not tested to work with certain
components
and so we really need to to to do a
better job i think collectively as
as as a group to make sure that we're
not mismatching these rotors tubes and
centrifuges it's a huge source of
unnecessary risk
how do we avoid accidents when it comes
to centrifugation
real simple questions is the instrument
level
does the motor control the rotor
smoothly or is it jerking
or making strange noises uh is the door
latching
right especially those of us in academia
we're probably used to using an
instrument that's a little old
and the latch doesn't always work it's a
bad idea
are the samples and materials found at
the bottom of the centrifuge
a simple question but one that needs to
be asked
when it comes to the rotor itself do i
know my maximum rotor speed
am i surpassing the maximum credible
accident parameters am i setting myself
up to unnecessary risk
have i balanced my rotors right um using
a balance to weigh
is maybe an extra step but really smart
move
okay checking the pins of the rotors for
cracks
and for corrosion pits as we showed in
the previous slide
and then checking the hinges on the
swing bucket
rotors another important aspect to
consider
getting down a little further into the
samples and tubes themselves
how do we avoid an accident does the
sample container have
integrity again do we visually inspect
it
and we see it as free of cracks or
deformities or dents
if it is great if not time to switch
them out
again confirming the presence of the
o-rings or the sealing mechanisms
very important in mitigating the risk
and on this fourth component again human
error do i know my maximum rotor speed
am i balancing my samples have i
exceeded the weight of the rotor
visual inspection or even using specific
tools
to determine if there's any cracks or
corrosions or pits
and then checking the buckets for hinge
points make sure that they're well
lubricated
and with integrity so going outside in
the centrifuge the rotor
samples and tubes and then we ourselves
the individuals running the separation
so let's switch gears take a little bit
of a biological workflow perspective
i know many of us might be tired of this
topic but it's quite relevant
and more important than ever let's talk
about sars cove 2
as a potential biohazard so in
laboratory biosafety guidelines related
to coronavirus from 2019 the covid
19. the who guidelines
have a laboratory biosafety manual third
edition
and in that comment generally they refer
to low speed
centrifuges with swing bucket rotors
and very noteworthy here is they mention
the preference for sealed cups in other
words
buckets sealed buckets in their
guidelines
this is a requirement that who
recommends when we're working
with an infectious disease like cyrus
cove two
and then there's an annex ii risk
assessment template
which one can use for developing these
safe standard practices
so this is a nice source this who
laboratory biosafety manual third
edition
again noting that a sealed bucket is a
requirement from their perspective
and that there's a really nice template
that they have that we can use to assess
and develop the standard practices
so i think
biosafety as we mentioned has always
been important beckman's always played a
role in it
we're going to continue to play a role
in it and due to the importance of bio
containment in modern labs
uh we do have i think a number of really
good options to address the needs
so i want to spend some time here
talking about
biosafe instruments and accessories and
bio-enhanced
instruments and accessories so
bio safety from a biologics workflow
perspective
here i think some important
certifications designations
that you would want to consider to
minimize your risk when it comes to
biosafety
biosafe and biosafety are in terms
intended to describe
any enhanced bio-containment features of
beckmann coulter life science products
bioenhanced describes our product's
enhanced level of bio containment by a
design
so if it's bio enhanced we have designed
it as a way
to improve on bio safety
this contrasts with bio c or bio
certified
now this is a term to describe our
products which have been
tested and validated to demonstrate
containment
of microbes and aerosols by an
independent third-party organization
so you can buy a bio-enhanced solution
and then send it to the health
protection agency
in fort detrick maryland to get
biocertified
and i think it's important to note here
that the improper use or
maintenance may affect
seal integrity and containment so
even when something is biocertified
there the maintenance and use are still
a strong consideration still
part of the equation to maintain that
biosafety
so biosafe bio-enhance is a term that we
use for the design of our
instruments and equipment and bio
certification
is something that you can have
designated to the instrument
after third-party testing by the health
protection agency
so i think some important aspects to
consider to give us another
level of risk minimization risk
mitigation
so let's put this all together when we
look at biosafety from this workflow
perspective
i'd like to look at it as a biosafety
russian doll if you will right so the
sum total of biosafety
let's talk about these three components
instruments
rotors sample labware so we're gonna
dive into here a little bit more when we
talk about risk
mitigation risk minimization
equipment maintenance certifications and
training
these four components i think are the
complete solution
when one is considering the best way to
mitigate risk
now looking at these other three
components the instrument the rotor and
the sample lab where
we want to look at this more as layers
of containment and control right
fail safes if you will so that if there
is an accident
maybe it just spills into the rotor and
not the instrument so we're going to
look at this as escalating levels of
containment and control
the last piece here and i think this
might be the spot where we could do the
the best to improve is the monitoring
and the reporting right
verifying the performance of the
instrument for example annual
certifications
many of us doing iq eqs
things like that very important i think
we could do a little better job on
training and and and on reporting these
things so
risk mitigation what equipment you're
using the maintenance the certification
the training
the bio containment system itself in
this case the centrifuge
instrument rotors and labware and then
the third piece is
us monitoring and reporting
so let's start outside go in from the
centrifuge
as cited in regulatory guidelines
payment of biohazards and infectious
agents
really is the essential element in
maintaining a safe work environment in
the lab
so preventing the release we
need to think about proper understanding
of the applications
and by extension the appropriate
equipment and bench technique
to accomplish those applications
particularly
relevant of course in infectious disease
biomedical and microbiological labs
and in these different bio safety level
labs right bsl
2 3 and 4.
so if we talk about the bioenhanced the
instruments that we have
that are by design meant to improve
biosafety
we have our avante je here as an example
and you'll see the little designation
next to the instrument name for
bio enhanced so this is what you want to
be looking for
when you're considering solutions to
provide containment against microbes
aerosols and other bio hazards
we also have the pharmaceutical grade
hepa
sterilizing filter it's an option
i recommend it you can go down to 0.2
microns in particle size so this is just
another
i think good layer of safety to minimize
risk
thereby mitigating the risk so
bio-enhanced
solutions for centrifuge with a
pharmaceutical grade
hepa sterilizing filter now diving down
to level two talking about the rotors
this is something i'm a big proponent of
and this is going to go back to my
warning about mismatching
manufacturers instruments equipment our
biocertified rotors are actually dual
locking
so they remain sealed and can act almost
as a bio containment hood for sample
retrieval
and as you see here we have the rotor
knob and this daisy knob
and they work against each other as a
dual locking solution
which i think is is a really nice
comfort level
um to protecting us when we are
separating
these hazards we have third party
certification i mentioned that earlier
we can take the documents and have
an independent third-party organization
in fort detrick maryland
um test and verify that and i cite them
below here
so uh for those of us working with
aerosols potential biosafety hazards
i highly recommend exploring the use of
dual locking rotor lids
another thing we talked about earlier
with the who
biosafety manual the third edition is
the
sealed nature of containment
so we have biocertified rotors that can
work with our tighter plate solutions so
these are locking lids
you can literally load underneath your
flow hood
lock them down walk them over to the
centrifuge
and have the confidence of another layer
of containment or security
for you and your co-workers so the
particle containment insurance
really is that these particles will not
exit
or escape this configuration
so we have assurances via our maximum
credible
accident associated with these
biocertified rotors
and then we have these large volume
canisters
so in this case both of these solutions
whether you're working with tubes or
tighter plates
we can again have them third-party
certified
by oc giving you another layer of
trust and security and monitoring of the
solution
now i think another important aspect
that is overlooked quite a bit in
centrifugation workflows that's
important here
it's the dynamic rotor inertia check a
very important safety tool for
mitigating potential risk
the overspeed discs
are prevented by a programming
that will not allow it to exceed maximum
speed
so if we naively or accidentally
decide to run these rotors
above the credible rate the dynamic
rotor inertia check will mitigate that
it will
stop the workflow stop the separation
the spinning
before there's a problem but
here's where i come back to this
mismatching manufacturers if you're
using
a beckman centrifuge with a non beckmann
rotor
these aren't going to necessarily work
for you so this is another reason why
it's important to stick with the
manufacturer
the dric calculates the rotor speed
acceleration pattern
essentially is looking to calculate the
energy potential
and if it determines we are going to
exceed that energy potential in the run
it will stop the run if the excess is
not resolved so i'm a big fan of this
very few manufacturers offer dric
capabilities
so again by mismatching different
manufacturers instruments
we may be taking away a very important
layer of safety and security in your
workflows
so it's important thing to consider
another key reason again for never
mixing manufacture centrifugations or
rotor solutions
so field rotor inspection if you don't
feel
comfortable with your knowledge or your
ability to inspect the rotors
you can call us the experts in and we
can help you with that
so we have a no charge field rotor
inspection we can come in
assess if everything has physical
integrity
from the results of the inspection the
field service engineer may make some
recommendations to you about the rotors
present or any issues
they may be noticing again it's no
charge
i think it's an important advantage to
take
with this knowledge uh and and during
this the lab personnel
will be instructed in the proper care of
the rotors so we can really
kind of help with the training and again
minimize the human error element
in this process so let's move on now to
the
inner layer of containment if you will
the labware itself
selecting the appropriate solution for
labware is
sometimes daunting but extremely
important
so we want to have considered certain
variables like maximum speed or the
g-force rating from the manufacturers
we want to look at chemical
incompatibility if we're using for
example organic solvents
we may have some issues if we don't use
the right chemical
resistant materials screw tops tubes and
bottles
for sealing are often very helpful and
something i recommend
we even have an optiseal tube here and
then again we have another solution an
aerosol canister and biosafe cover so i
highly recommend this as a solution
it will actually make it easier for you
in your workflow and it will minimize
risk here so these are just some things
to consider when we're talking about
labware
now i really want to dive down on this
hance bio safety
i think this is a very simple solution
that we can use it will help with
compliance
the solution itself is transparent so
you can have a visual inspection if you
do have a leak or an aerosol
spill you don't have to wait to open the
container to see that
we have bucket covers for 1.5 mil
tubes to 750 ml bottles
and again we also have the micro plates
so this to me
is a very simple solution we can take
that will greatly enhance
bio safety here i cite the chemical
compatibility
so i think beckman does a great job here
uh really trying to help
make this potentially daunting subject
of chemical compatibility a little
easier here
so we have all the properties on the
left hand side and the different
materials and whether or not they work
together
and and so i have it here all in one
simple solution for you
now instrument design solutions
taking these centrifuge rotor 321
and putting it together to design the
correct
instrument solution ahead of time
and in here is where i recommend a tool
you can use on our website called
intellifuge
it takes time asking you parameters
about
your workflow and considers
recommendations on rotors
tubes and centrifuges so we can
calculate with speed
very quickly determine what the best
configuration
for your application needs in centrifuge
so i
i'm a big proponent of this solution it
can prevent you from
purchasing the wrong solution from
implementing the wrong
solution and really give you some
visibility
on proper design instead of
patchworking the solution over time so
the intellifuges
is a tool i recommend uh
that you look into when you're trying to
design an
optimal centrifuge solution for your
workflows
so let's summarize the talk uh the
importance of biosafety in the lab
when it comes through minimizing risk
and mitigating risk it's containment and
control
monitoring and reporting these are
really the two pillars of planning
that we personally in the lab can take
an active role
in defining there is an oversight
organization in place
that defines and manages guidance of the
framework
but the challenge really comes to again
taking this regulatory comment
and implementing it into the your
specific environment because
you are the expert you understand the
details
in your lab better than these regulatory
organizations
and then lastly we should not consider
biosafety as a one-size-fits-all
solution
there are different considerations
within labs
between labs across laboratory
organizations
so the degree of risk potential can vary
and not all the solutions
options out there serve as viable
solutions to biosafety
with that i'd like to thank you all for
your time and attention
and happy to entertain any questions
comments or
considerations in the panel discussion
thank you thank you dr lentz for your
informative presentation
before we begin the q a session we would
like to revisit the poll questions
mentioned earlier in the presentation
they will pop up in your screen in just
a moment
dr lentz would you like to reread the
questions aloud
sure i'd be happy to do that and
jennifer thanks for hosting
sure let's start with the first poll
question that we mentioned earlier
in the presentation how familiar are you
with the individuals
that are part of the biosafety committee
for your organization so there's your
options there
anywhere from yes i know them all to
know i can't name a single person
or i'm not even sure if we have a
biosafety committee so i'll take a
moment or two
to reflect on that poll question
okay so for the next poll question
how often does your organization perform
biosafety audits
of your laboratory facilities so there's
some options there to choose from and
take a few seconds to allow you to do
that
okay moving on to the third poll
question
how familiar with 42 cfr 73
and related federal guidelines
comprising lab safety so true or false
your familiarity with the cfr guideline
and for the last poll question
if you'd like to feel a little bit safer
about biosafety a little
better understanding you can select true
and
and we can have a beckmann coulter life
science specialist reach out to you and
assist you with that if you feel
comfortable with
the current state of bio safety you
choose false
great thank you for facilitating that dr
lentz
and now we would like to start the live
q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
okay let's get started and our first
question is
let's see in your uh personal
of the record opinion um was sars kobe 2
pandemic a result of a biosafety
accident
that's an interesting question that
is a great first question whoever is
that thank you
um we need to follow the data
right opinions need to be formed by data
there are some data out there that
suggest
strongly that it was an accident
that perpetuated this situation
presumably in the wild we had
determined what is now sars cove ii
brought it into the labs bad technique
bad performance
uh bad instrumentation may have had
a strong role in allowing this
infectious agent to get back out so
great question very timely and and yes
a good real world example of of the
potential
for human error or or bad technique
to have uh propagated this situation
did i answer the question okay let me
now if they did not
okay yes um if you have another question
or would like to expand on that would
like dr lentz to expand on that
you can just type it into the ask a
question box
our next question let's see could you
provide a copy of your chemical combat
compatibility chart for centrifuge tubes
i'd be happy to do that um and if it
would also help we can give
a link to the intellifuge so you can
play around with the parameters and get
an understanding of how to design the
safety of the instrument
we'll include the chemical compatibility
and perhaps maybe getting ahead of
another need the iec
comment if that would be helpful to the
to the participants
okay thank you dr lentz and we have
another question here
could you please repeat the terms
associated with centrifuge biosafety
what is the difference between bio e and
bio c again
yep okay good um the minutia can be
sometimes difficult to to recall
so bioenhanced is us the manufacturer
by design improving the potential for
biosafety in the instrumentation
bioc or biocertification is a validation
of the equipment by a third party with
expertise
in the subject matter so in other words
one could buy a bio-enhanced
solution and not have it bio-certified
right but i think a complete solution
would include the biocertification by
the third party
so hopefully that'll kind of clear the
differences up there
thank you dr lentz we have another
question coming in
what suggestions do you have for what
our labs should be monitoring and
reporting for centrifugation biosafety
these are all very good questions um
especially for monday morning right
that again there's not a
one-size-fits-all
you really have to play an active role
as the expert in the equation
but when it comes to biosafety with
centrifugation
we're looking at things like
biocontainment maximum credible
accident uh specific design
solutions to help mitigate risk like uh
like our our disc rotor inertia check
for example i would recommend
if there are some questions the best
course of action
is to reach out to an expert and the two
groups specman culture life sciences in
your organization
will work together to make a good
solution for you
perfect thank you dr lentz and our next
question
could we go back to the topic of frips
again this is the first time i've heard
of this topic is that related to k
factor uh no good question
so fripps uh acronym for field
rotor inspection this is a
service we would provide to you pro bono
right at no charge
to help assess the quality of your
rotors
and to understand how to maintain them
and to mitigate any potential challenges
k factor on the other hand is
essentially a measure of
your efficiencies in separating
materials so i think many of us
maybe erroneously assume that the speed
is the efficiency right the rpms of the
rotor
but that is only one part of the
variable one variable in the equation
the k factor is looking at the sum total
efficiency
in separation and in time and i think
really that's the factor you want to
look at for the workflow itself
does that make sense k factor as a
summation
of how efficient your centrifuge system
is in separating the materials of
interest
uh different from frips field rotor
inspection to make sure that the
system you're using has integrity
and can allow that k factor
to to propagate safely
if that was unclear that answered please
let me know
i'm happy to elaborate
perfect thank you dr lentz and our next
question could you please state the
organization responsible for performing
the validations
so uh this is a long acronym
in fort detrick uh it's the validation
system off the top of my head i don't
remember exactly
the order of the word so i don't want to
say something a mislead
um but is the third-party organization
that many of us use
um they're not related to beckman or any
other manufacturers
they are responsible for
biocertification i apologize for not
remembering the exact acronym off the
top of my head
but i can provide that to you after the
talk no problem thank you so much dr
lentz uh before we go do you have any
final comments for the audience today
yes only uh first of all thanks for your
time and attention
um hopefully the material presented
was of interest to you i know it's not
always the most exciting topic
oftentimes we want to talk about the
science itself but i think this is very
important
uh i hope it helps guide your your
behaviors your thoughts
in bio safety and maybe clarifies it a
little bit
more give some framework around what can
potentially be
maybe a little confusing topic if you do
have additional comments or questions or
concerns
of course we are available to help you
please feel free to reach out
and i believe we'll be making a
recording of this presentation available
afterwards as well so i really want to
thank you for your time and attention
and hopefully i i provided some value to
you and what you do every day
well thank you again dr lentz for your
time today and for your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor beckman culture life
sciences
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye